hello and welcome to the Daily climate
show coming up today
the UN warns that some of the world's
most famous glaciers including
Kilimanjaro and the dolomites will
disappear by 2050.
warmer and stormier weather is blamed
for an increase in the number of
jellyfish in the UK Waters
and staying with the ocean theme we
speak to the endurance swimmer Louis
Pugh who ahead of cop 27 has just
completed the first ever crossing of the
Red Sea
foreign
to the Daily climate show where we track
the changes to our world and interrogate
some of the potential solutions to The
Climate crisis now we begin with a
warning from the United Nations about
the frightening number of glaciers under
threats from climate change even if the
planet doesn't get any warmer than it is
now they include glaciers in Europe
North America and even Africa now a
third of the 18 600 glaciers monitored
by the un's cultural agency UNESCO are
set to Disappear by 2050 whatever the
temperature rise scenario now among
those set to disappear are the Italian
dolomites in the Yosemite National Park
in the U.S and also in the U.S the
glacier in Yellowstone Park and in
Tanzania on Mount Kilimanjaro Africa's
highest point and while the rest can be
saved by keeping the global temperature
rise below 1.5 degrees celsius if global
warming continues news at its current
rate about half of all world heritage
glaciers could almost entirely Disappear
by the end of the century a world
heritage Glacier lose on average 58
billion tons of ice every year
equivalent to the total annual volume of
water used in France and Spain together
and that contributes to almost five
percent of the rise in the rise in
global sea levels our science
correspondent Thomas Moore joins us in
the studio so Thomas this it's Bleak
what are the implications you know until
the middle of the last century glasses
were stable they weren't losing an awful
lot of advice not setting up more than
they were accumulating during the winter
but that all changed in the second half
of the last century and it's
accelerating so we're seeing big losses
of ice now which are increasing sea
levels but also having big local effects
because a large number of people that
depend on glacier water to drink and
also to irrigate their crops now at the
moment it's all coming down in a flood
but in a few decades time it's and
completely dry up and it's going to have
huge problems for people and their food
security I suppose a real example was
earlier this year wasn't it the
Avalanche the marmalade the largest
glacier the Italian dolomites a huge
impact several people died with this
huge slab of Ice broke off the front of
the glassy and just tumbled down into
the valley and and that is an example of
what is happening to these glasses now
it had been 10 degrees the day before
bear in mind this is 2 800 meters up in
the Alps it is a a phenomenal
temperature and of course Europe had
record temperatures over the summer and
that has increased the heating but also
there was very much a very little
snowfall over the last winter and that
normally act as a duvet over the ice and
shelter it from the very high summer
temperatures the two things combined are
having a really terrible effect on the
Alps and the glaciers indeed Stark
warnings there thank you very much
Thomas More
okay only three days to go now until cop
27 begins and the Egyptian Red Sea
Resorts of charmel Sheikh um we now know
don't we that Rishi sunak will travel
there for the world leaders Summits at
the beginning of next week well today
his climate Minister told Sky News How
concerned he was that the world is not
on track to meet targets to limit global
warming but when asked about the UK's
own climate pledges Graham Stewart
defended the government's controversial
decision to open a new licensing round
for companies to explore for oil and gas
in the North Sea saying the move will be
greener in the long term
we are absolutely focused on making sure
that the Glasgow climate pact is
converted into action
um and as you say the world is not on
track for 1.5 degrees we're managing the
decline of the Basin it is expected with
new licenses that it'll still be
reducing at about seven percent a year
faster than the globe needs to cut its
oil and gas and producing our own energy
here to ever higher environmental
standards
stopping us spending billions on
bringing in oil and gas from other
countries it's a weird argument when you
you're going to have to burn oil and gas
up to 2050 and through 2050 even on Net
Zero
and on the great debate on Monday when
cop 27 will be underway We'll be asking
can we afford to prioritize the climate
at a time when the cost of living is
taking Center Stage is it possible to
retain the necessary financial and
political Focus required to solve the
climate crisis email the great debate at
sky.uk to join the audience and share
your views and tune in at nine next
Monday evening
now a new farming report has warned that
food companies and governments must come
together immediately to change the
world's agricultural practices or risks
destroying the planet the report says
the pace of change in the industry has
been far too slow and says it must
triple by 2030 for the world to have any
chance of keeping global warming under
control
an increase in jellyfish numbers along
the British Coastline has been recorded
with warmer sea temperatures being
pointed to for the rise
1315 jellyfish sightings were reported
to the marine conservation Society for
its annual review this included an
increase in the sightings of the
Portuguese Mano War a jellyfish-like
creature with a sting that can be very
painful with their rise put down to
Stormy Weather
well let's hope there weren't too many
jellyfish around when the endurance
swimmer and um patron of the oceans
Lewis Pugh completed the world's first
swim across the Red Sea that was only
last week well the swim of over a
hundred miles was done to draw attention
to the threat climate change is posing
to coral reefs in the swim began off the
Tehran Islands in Saudi Arabia and
finished in Egypt where cop 27 begins on
Sunday in Lewis is calling on
governments to take action to
significantly cut their greenhouse gas
emissions and for 30 percent of the
world's oceans to be protected and well
Lewis he joins us now Lewis how are you
thanks so much for joining us on the
daily climate show
thank you so much I'm really happy to
speak to you and relieve that this swim
was over it took an awful long time 16
days all the way across the Red Sea very
very warm water
uh but uh relieved to have made it oh
you made it didn't you what a journey
that was for you and it's clear that you
did this endurance swim to highlight the
climate crisis but do you believe ahead
of cop27 the right people are listening
I certainly hope so I mean I swam over
some of the most incredible Coral you
can ever imagine I mean uh I swam
through the Raz Muhammad National Park
and just looking down the cult the
colors of the coral the beautiful greens
and the yellows and the purples and
tropical fish goldfish sharks manta rays
Turtles it was absolutely amazing but
the science is clear and the science is
that if we continue to heat our planets
they're really at risk if we the
scientists tell us if we heat the plant
by 1.5 degrees Centigrade we will lose
70 percent of the world's Coral if we
heated by over two degrees then we're
liable to lose 99 of the world's coral
and currently we're on track for way
past that so that'll be my message to
the delegates at cop27 in charm or Shake
please come and put your head in the
water look at the incredible Coral that
we have there this supports nearly a
quarter of life in our oceans and we
cannot afford to lose it
so you encourage then that the Prime
Minister Rishi sunak has decided to
attend
yes I I'm very very happy that he's
attending you know the climate crisis is
the defining issue of Our Generation yes
he's just become Prime Minister he's got
a lot of stuff on his plate but this is
unlike anything that we are facing it's
going to impact every single person on
this planet every future generation the
whole of the animal kingdom it's right
that the prime minister of the United
Kingdom is there uh supporting all
efforts now to reduce our emissions and
to protect the oceans further
and Louis you've said that cop 27 there
needs to be urgent action what do you
think that urgent action needs to look
like
well it's it's two things principally
number one is cutting emissions and
every single government has got to do it
it can't be pointing to some governments
and saying they've got to do more or
less all of us have now got to put our
shoulder to the wheel and then secondly
I'm urging world leaders to commit to
this target of protecting 30 of the
world's oceans over this decade and we
now need to crack on we now need to
create these large protected areas and
we know that the science of them is that
when we create these large protected
areas the wildlife in them rebounds it's
like creating big national parks on land
okay Louis P thank you very much for
joining us and I hope you get a
well-earned rest now thank you thank you
and uh just before we go just a reminder
that ahead of cop27 beginning on Sunday
our weekly climate Show with Tom Heap is
back this weekend and you can watch it
on Saturdays and Sundays at 3 30 in the
afternoon or at 7 30 in the evening
but for today from the team that's all
from us thanks for watching
[Music]